if you're watching in the future on
YouTube
I'm on a website called pyches.org
and this is a leechas sister website for
chess variants they recently added the
duck chess variant
and this will be my first time
playing an AI in Duck chess
and twitch chat wants me to speedrun the
AI levels so we're starting with the the
worst level let's just hop into it
um I don't think I should start with too
many minutes maybe I'll play like 2-2
and
this is gonna feel a bit oh oh no
oh no
is it broken
did I break it
ABC what is this
where's my duck
clear your browser cache
how do I do that
okay trying this again I'm in incognito
play with AI duck it's our anniversary
Eric I hope you've remembered to get me
a card
um
I'll get you more than the card I'll get
you some duck chest content hopefully
no promises at this point though
hey it works okay
oh no my duck
oh I'm so happy right now
so I'm playing fairy stockfish level
zero
so this is
supposedly the weakest version
of the AI
and wow it moves fast
is there sound
unmute
there is sound
hopefully it's not too loud
sound
okay
oh no my duck
oh yes my duck
oh wow it plays really fast it's
actually not playing so bad
so one key is to trade the bishop for
Knight
oh this is so much like snappier
catastrophe avoided
oh it's so weird playing on a different
interface
okay threading this let's see if it sees
my threat oh it didn't see my threat
oh yes
uh
how do I want to do this
I gotta watch my time oh no White's
Queen
okay this is beautiful oh oh wow It's
Tricky actually if I take the bishop
I lose my queen
so let's play this and this hitting the
knight in Bishop
wow
578 days of Ono
wow was
it's actually kind of good
I was expecting it to be weak but that's
a fascinating move
I think I'll just taken
duck C2
it's gonna take here
so one cool thing about duck chess you
can Castle while in check
because there's no official like check
in this game
okay it just gave me a free rook
uh and a free Bishop
okay let's destroy it now
how difficult is it going to be to
checkmate
[Music]
um
I need the pawn to help out
this is going to allow this
hey okay it's duck Meats GG
oh yes
okay
I hope that was enjoyable that was
enjoyable for me
I was a fast game
realizing I can improve the layout a
little bit
make myself bigger here
congrats on 600k YouTube Subs oh thanks
so much enjoy your streams and have
learned a lot
I enjoy your words so that was level
zero
now it's time for level one
I'm black again
oh it's so fast
oh let's not hang a king
yeah this is um
this should be pretty straightforward to
beat
I'm going to try and orchestrate some
funny
um smothered mates like maybe this
is gonna hang mate wow it hangs mate
okay so this is a very common mating
pattern in Duck chess
um H3 looks like a natural move to hit
the Knight
and actually I guess I could throw this
to chat
um it's black to move and duck made in
one
and to Define duck mate it's basically
you you make a move you move the duck
and then opponent has no Escape
also do people like this design of the
duck
I like the circle around the duck
good job to everyone saying Bishop H2
and duck H1
oh it's double check
I could just torment my opponent Queen
F2 duck H1
just for fun
okay
had to put white out of their misery
okay so that was level one level two
I feel like it's gonna get harder
dough I'm black again
the random color algorithm is uh
not wanting me to move first it plays E3
every game it seems like
but I wonder what the stronger levels
will play
so again this is a speed run so yeah I'm
trying to move quickly
grabbing space
uh let's defend
yeah that's a free piece
that's another free piece
so far this engine isn't too impressive
uh although I don't want to get my queen
trapped in this move
foreign
some like basic ways of attacking
oh that was that was very clever it
understands anti-ampa song
which is kind of annoying
but so far I'm liking the way this is
progressing
um
let's play this and this
okay so we got rid of both my Knights
but I'm up two Bishops here
and I'll keep putting the duck back on
E2
hear this move
oh wow it attacks in both directions so
I have to be careful not to hang my king
maybe this and this
oh that doesn't work how's the free
Queen
I'll block the e-file take a pong
uh Castle
[Music]
never too late to Castle
and now now it's a matter of like
finishing off the King which is
sometimes like surprisingly difficult
but
I'm gonna try and coordinate the pieces
like so
I think this is almost duckmates
oh not quite is this dog mates
there we go okay
okay
so that was level two
there's eight levels
and we are going back to home page
and playing with AI level three
I'm black again
oh let's let's try this funny opening
trap this D5 uh it's not letting me
though
oops that was a duck slip
wow it's playing weirdly I think I can
take and then win
at least upon
guaranteeing that F6
oh
the king is kind of precarious there
it's hard to exploit though
I want the queensy come in
oops
yeah it's not doing a great job of like
preventing me what I want to do
just nice
I think I'll take generally the Knight
should be more valuable than the Rook
oh fancy but
that's a free material
okay here we go going for the kill
[Music]
I like this move uh Rook F2 and duck E3
so the point is when the ducks on E3 the
king if it takes on the duck has to move
and I win the king
and now I have a queen here in this
and this and this
and GG
okay that was satisfying
it's weird how it puts a duck on G2 in
the final
[Music]
the very final moment of that game
oh hey welcome CDR Siri
asking have you ever played duck chess
OTV
yeah you should check out my most recent
YouTube video it features otv.chess
I think my first it's probably the first
OTB dock chess video I posted
okay
here we go
level four halfway there almost
play E4 ducky six
apologies if these games are kind of
fast and maybe hard to follow but
again that's kind of the the point of a
speed run
so going for positional play it's clear
it's um the level's improving wait what
move the duck
yeah it's definitely getting stronger
but still making like plungers
um let's play this and this
foreign
The Rook
oh that was a bad move
oops I can't undo it either
oh no
okay I guess I have duck D5
am I queen ah
do I want to lose a queen
I kind of have to
play Queen H4 dug H6 but I lose a knight
I think I'm better off giving the queen
uh
okay so I'm technically down material
[Music]
am I
don't think it's so bad though
but it's not great
okay let's play this and then this
my Knight's still attacked
I didn't think this through thoroughly
oh it didn't take my Bishop though
I'm gladly save the bishop
Ricky Chase
okay this this is looking much better
now
let's play this
and then this and then this
oh I didn't see that
wait a minute this
and then this
oh the King still survives wow okay I
can take
I'm trying oh can I not win the pawn
and move so fast too
oh we have some end game
okay let's attack from behind
take that
County orchestrate some mating attack
how do I get the job done either this
and then this
and it's so easy to move quickly here
oh wow okay I have to play this and then
this
okay this and this
it's not easy to like actually win the
position
There Goes My Bishop
ah how do I win this
I mean I'm up at night so it shouldn't
be too difficult
there we go there goes a rook
and basically I don't need my king or
Knight or um I don't need my knight or
Rook I'm just gonna box out the king
I'm really hoping it's programmed the
same way as it is on chess.com
because after King F1 dug H2 why can't I
draw the arrow to each two
King F1 dug H2
normally this would be still me this is
for normal chest but in Duck chess the
King has to move to my king
yeah
it's one of those nice cases where the
kings are next to each other
okay
so that's level four that was by far the
most difficult level so far I'm kind of
scared that it's gonna beat me
by the time I reach level eight but so
far I'm undefeated
uh let's go back
play with AI level five here we go
so level five
I have to be a bit more alert and
because it's true too I also have to
manage my time
so here we go
[Music]
um
which I want to play maybe I'll play
another six in the ducky five
interesting let's play this sign oh
I blundered no one's ever done this to
me I can't play Knight before
that's unfortunate
I guess I have to move here and here
oh no I'll move back to B6 hopefully
now I can take in this I think this is
okay
now I can start harassing the bishop
but I can tell it's getting stronger
with every level
wait what I'm just giving you a free
Queen
this better not be some deep duck
sacrifice
wait I I'm so confused what it's doing I
thought it's supposed to be stronger not
weaker
let's just save the bishop
I just want a queen
uh some check and then maybe this
yeah let's start having fun with the
King
it's not easy to meet though or is it
I was fighting this but I have this and
this
wow that was one of the easier games
I was just plundered as Queen and then
proceeded to get mated
um
yeah this is already duck needs like the
King has no escape the duck will have to
move away and I'm controlling all these
squares
but the opening I did get tricked
so I should not repeat that
this um
what happened
yeah taking and duck before preventing
night before
okay we move on that was level five
there's three more levels
level six
I assume level six will be less
uh less generous
so let's develop
ment
wow what is this
some new weird strategy I can't play G6
because I hang a knight I can play this
wow that's so weird
but I can't easily attack the queen
because
I can't play this can't play this
I guess just D6
and then this
wow
avoiding the queen trade
I'm gonna try and drop the queen because
it's really close to being trapped
play this and then this
unleashing the bishop
and now this and this hitting the queen
ah the queen ran away though
okay it still looks fine
but it's moving instantly every move
which is slightly terrifying
[Music]
okay so I can win a pawn
move back
and this move
how to do this maybe this
wait what it gave its Queen again
oh wow
if I take it it's gonna play this and
then duck h8 no it can't though I can't
move
wait I'm so confused
I'm gonna play duck HH for good measure
just so I have Kimmy shades
I think it's just blundered
uh let's prevent Rook G1
yeah I just gave its Queen again
but I'm low on time so I have to be
careful
play this and then have this trapping
the Knight
check
yeah this and this circle oh my Queen's
hanging though
so I'll take and then this
okay this should be winning
I just have to move more quickly
wow is this
put all the pieces around the king
but where's my duck mate
I have 26 seconds
so frustrating
is this working
this is duck mate I think
let's go okay
ah it was a stressful game
it sacked its Queen out of nowhere I
think it still has some issues
understanding like tactics or cryptics
also just to show this final dog mate
um Queenie one ducky two
when the duck is between the rook and
queen like this it's essentially a way
of defending the queen
okay moving up to level seven
so far I'm not so impressed
but we'll see if it uh if it's saving
the stronger levels for
the highest level
seven
I've been black ever again
but I guess it's a fair handicap if
I mean
it has an effect of the result too much
okay
interesting it doesn't play duck D6 but
it prevents Pawn D5
I'll play Queen's Indian setup
chance of getting black 7x
0.7 yeah I think I've been hitting the
random color button but
it's been
yeah it's it's been giving me back every
game
okay so I have two knights which
generally should be preferable
I have to watch out G4 G5 might be
coming
E7
okay
yeah this is more positional
it's actually interesting like you a
positional game probably is what I want
against a stronger form of the engine
[Music]
because I can employ more long-term
ideas
like make gradual improvements I'm not
going to be winning immediately after a
while
but yeah long term the knights should
Prosper I would hope
I'll play B5 soon
I hung up on uh
opponent doesn't take it though and
allows a fork
okay
a nice gift
I only get the Knight C4
late night C4 forking the queen and king
yeah I can't handle my tactics or my
craftix I should say
yeah this is gonna be another like
pretty straightforward win let's go
it definitely played the beginning of
the game more cleanly though
but I don't think it understands the
value of Knights versus Bishops
yeah no mercy here
that's already quack made or duck meat
I like how it takes one additional
second to
uh
to realize that there's no Escape
so that was level seven
um level eight is supposedly the
strongest
duck a i back to homepage again this is
piechest.org
py chess link is in the Stream title
and level eight random color playing two
plus two
hey I'm white okay
uh we'll see it's opening
E4 duck E6
so I'm gonna assume that's not oh G5
what what G5
I was gonna say that I would assume it
won't be blundering things
but it just gave me a pawn
some new Gambit innovation
it's kind of annoying to develop the
king side
I'll expand on the queen side
and G3
okay yeah it's still I mean they might
want to take next
so let's block the diagonal
I'm up a pawn but yeah material and duck
chest it's weird like it doesn't mean as
much compared to normal chess
wow there's three attackers and there's
this to worry about
so I guess I'll play like
hmm
I can't spend too much time here maybe
Queen C4 duck
B5
if I take and
I'm gonna block the bishop
oh no
oh if duck B1 I had Rook A2
I still have rookie too
you still might have rookie too
let me try and trap the queen
I feel like it's risky getting a
classical position here
okay
it's so close to driving Queen 92 and
duck D2
I think traps a queen
there might be a counter attack okay
maybe not
okay I won the queen
I'm really down on time
and it still has Bishops
interesting Rook takes Knight is
probably a reasonable trade
simplify a bit
I was not interested in my knight
oh
um looking for the duck meat
play this and this
I feel like it's so easy to blunder here
stop stop
harassing me wait Free Pawn
that was a free Pawn
uh let's move in for the kill
I'll just keep putting the duck back on
E5
like this
how to do this like knife F5
it's so close
yeah this escapes but now I have this
and this
um
making progress happy half year
so far down on time
I'm better but I'm I need to move
quicker
there's two second increments
okay that's um a funny anti-ampa song
as a duck slip
I'm gonna win this Pawn
that's winning my Pawn
stop it
I'm nervous
take that thing
I'm up a queen how hard this can this be
wait no I want to take the bishop
ah missed my chance
wait let me just Queen these Pawns
the duck can only stop one Pawn at a
time
[Music]
okay it's still hovering around 15
seconds
how does it stop how is he stopping all
my Pawns
this is so frustrating
okay let's make progress
[Music]
um
slowly but surely okay Bishop is stuck
it takes so much patience against an
engine like this
ah is it winning my Pawn no
[Music]
it's okay I won The Rook
okay this should be pretty
straightforward now
they keep saving its Bishop
and the blockades might Pawn
okay donated that
wait this is duck meat
let's go
wait no it's not talkingate
I thought I was meeting
wait let's not stalemate
that's basically impossible to stalemate
in the scheme
there we go
there we go okay
that's so difficult to win
okay level eight was probably the the
more difficult level
anyway
um
that was fun my first duck chess
match essentially against uh the
stockfish the fairy stockfish
um it's too bad we can't see what it's
thinking
but it was fun to play and it's
definitely
yeah definitely on the level like I'd
say much better than the average human
um so I'll probably put this whole thing
on YouTube
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube I hope you enjoyed this I'll
leave a link in the video description
if you want to play uh duck chess on pie
chess
pychest.org